hello welcome to the CEO playing roman
polanski here not the real one I guess
so g3 or see if I go see for play both
moves okay here I go I play d4 ng3 let's
see what we get it's symmetrical line
yeah I like to keep that night give the
nights on so we don't have that many
early simplifications know the diagonal
is a little bit weakened but my night on
c2 is protecting that rook so there are
no fancy moves working for black okay
cp5 is not happening that quickly so I'm
ready for 93 and possibly 95 yeah this
type of position is very solid for black
but should normally give white some
hopes for slight advantage I just got a
little bit more space and the OS has
that option of putting in Knight to g5
and this is often the problem e 6 is not
always a happy move for black to kick it
away and yeah it's not so easy to play
if you have to live with that the denied
position down all the time okay so
here's I'm trying to be ready to drag
queens on 95 yeah that looks like a
decent move
it's covered the Queen I don't want to
go 95 here necessarily because trade
some help like okay my idea was that I
have maybe this a night f4 sometimes
doing times playing against so slightly
weakened pawns they're like g6 and so on
but it's it's nothing clear going on oh
he takes it that's surprising
yeah maybe no 95 is infected move I mean
it wasn't before because of F forward
with age for being played he's got this
ok let's 45 c 3 a little bit I was
thinking about Queen f4 here for
possible before maybe try for that not
right it's not one move trap or so one
move threat but I just want to get rid
of the night he's not reacting to it
right or what's the big deal Queen B 6 I
couldn't be sexy wants to play Queen B 6
is possible maybe you should of course
you should should try it of course if i
take c 5 queen be too yeah that's
possible will be 6 is still playable and
what can I do ok whoa so I can at least
win a pawn if I playing Queen to f7
Queen takes f7 I can also take em that
that should be pretty good again I can
take a seven I think i will do that
right or if i take a 5 i'm winning a
whole piece huh yeah i'm winning a whole
p.m.
yeah get sets a full-piece you could
have played Quinn b6 I don't think that
this was so clear
so what about this let's cover that
bishop so that I'm ready to move the
night finally to d5
okay so i am taking this to go here keep
you two protected i will grab be 7 next
ok you can cover it down root g seven or
so it it's not changing much let's go 2
nite c 5
hmm okay
yeah it's okay though let's see five
rupee one we trade one pair of roofs
something that I definitely don't mind
him so attacking this pawn would be good
maybe I bring the night over to d3
yeah I think you should you didn't think
II should have taken okay it's a it's a
piece anyway but very faint hopes IAM
that before 96 should be pretty
convincing check
yeah Peter in the waste of time don't
you play this but I came black resides
okay so the critical position obviously
after Queen f4 I think there's not much
going on down and so pretty okay for
black we can't go naija for and actually
be better I'm not yet understanding why
hmm my queen okay it's bishop age 6 okay
okay okay I'm getting it okay now I can
go back to D 2 which is not nothing much
now so he went here and now it is I
think he can still do this there is no
clear way for me to refute this the
engine gives this room C 296 a 3 and
okay this is a bad piece but black is
definitely not lost or anything remotely
like that now they can still play that
position and here this is just winning
yeah it's just a piece and after that
nothing special happened so Queen f4
wasn't a good move but it yeah it set
him some direct problems that he yeah
couldn't couldn't solve this particular
moment okay well thanks for watching